[Music]
Um,
all right.
Choose to mirror or extend display. I'd
love to have my notes from the house
slides, please. Thank you. All right.
How are we feeling?
I hope you're not as exhausted as me,
but sufficiently exhausted. I hope we
all had a wonderful conference. But we
have one more special treat for you.
We're excited to present the finalists
for the very first official AI engineer
hackathon.
We partnered with Cerebral Valley, the
largest AI community in the world and
legends right here in the Bay Area for
running hackathons for the very first
official AI engineer hackathon. From 500
applicants, 160 engineers came together
to learn, connect, and build together.
46 projects presented on site and three
were selected as finalists. And today we
have those three finalists with us and
they will each present their 48 hour
builds for us in under five minutes. And
all of you in the audience are going to
be the judge. But thanks to being
smitten by the Wi-Fi gods, we have
decided to go old Athenian style by the
roar of the crowd. Are you not
entertained?
The three teams listed here in the order
that they will present. Have we
confirmed that Ro? Is this the actual
order they're coming on? I certainly
hope so. Team one, survival of the
future.
Team two, tab RL. Team three,
featherless action R1. Do what you have
to do to remember the order. take some
notes on what you like best because
we're gonna come back and roar as soon
as they're done after these 15 minutes.
So, I'll let Swix proceed with the
intro. Uh yeah, these are all very uh
competitive teams. I think they're
coming up now. Um they are what can I
say? I was actually I think in the room
when the these guys were presenting for
the final round. Um and like everyone
was uh very very impressed like they
were like how does this not exist
already? So, um I think I should just
kind of let them take it away because I
don't want to steal their thunder. But,
um I did insist on printing these
trophies. Uh so, we're going to hand
them out. Um it's mostly just
appreciation, but uh I think we also
want to try to make AI engineer a place
where people can get recognition for
their work uh by speaking, by posting.
Thank you. We worked really hard on
these. They got here um two hours ago.
Uh overnight delivery started on Monday
and then went to Tuesday. Uh and and
anyway, so um I think these are ready,
so I don't want to take away your time.
Survival of the future, folks.
[Applause]
So we're at here at the World's Fair and
we're all builders. So we want to ship
as fast as possible so we can get
feedback from users as fast as possible,
shorten the feedback loop to know
whether we're moving in the right
direction.
But a lot of the time, making progress
toward optimizing UX can totally feel
like shooting in the dark.
Why is it so hard to optimize UX? Well,
in order to find the right message for
users, you have to subject yourself to
the painstakingly iterative trial and
error process of creating and testing
variations. A lot of the times these
changes can look like really small
tweaks to copy oneline code changes.
The variations are endless. In addition,
AB testing pipelines can be super
clunky. So you can wait to gather the
data and then once you get the data, the
the signal is still not clear and you're
not sure how to proceed. All the while,
sometimes the product is changing or
sometimes we need the feedback from the
users in the first place to figure out
what the product is.
How do we use AI agents to improve this
process?
Our product uses agents to automate
those small refinements, the oneline
code changes, and push those to
production um and review the data in
real time. This frees up resources for
teams to focus on the big picture
problems and improvements. Meanwhile,
our agents are reviewing the data and
refining the AB testing to maximize the
value of information that can be gained
from user behavior from these changes.
This one.
So for our current workflow, we have a
pretty easy integration with your GitHub
that you can uh just in increment it to
your GitHub. Choose whatever repo that
you want that has some sort of front
end. Uh we have one agent that's going
to look for your either your landing
page or your the dashboard that the
users have the most uh integration with
and then another agent is going to try
to look analyze it and try to look to
make like very small integrations to
those pages. Or if you're already in the
data pipeline, we can also use previous
feedbacks from the user interactions to
give that agent to make like better uh
integrations depend on how previous
interactions worked. And then after that
agent is done, it's going to make a
branch in just just to your repo.
And the other agent can uh traffic user
data again based on previous recordings
of how the users were interacting with
those components. It's going to traffic
like a very small percentage of the user
data to that new variant that we made
and it's going to keep doing that until
you make uh better and better variants
for your product.
So, we're currently building out
capabilities to solve for the metrics
that matter the most. So, our customers
can customize what they want to solve
for to maximize the value of real-time
user feedback. LLMs and user feedback
are a match made in heaven. This also
means that UX engineers don't have to
babysit their features because this
process is run by agents. So again,
teams can res can focus on the metrics
that matter the most while working on
the big picture improvements and
decisions.
All the while, our agents are analyzing
the user data, providing a refined
approach to AB testing and introducing a
soft launch of updates and changes so
that as more and more users respond
positively to these changes, they're
shown to more and more users and you can
push changes to production safely and
with confidence. This is a massive
improvement over the current process
because who hasn't had the experience of
pushing to production and it doesn't
turn out how you were hoping it would.
So our agent does three things. It takes
care of the busy work and those
incremental changes. It frees up
resources for teams to focus on the big
picture and it improves on the current
AB process by incrementalizing it and
refining it. So you can push code to
production. um more confidently, more
safely, and reduce that risk.
Thank you.
And if you scan this QR code, it'll take
you to our website so you can check it
out.
Awesome. Um thanks to Lori, Salem, um
and what was Armen. Uh thank you. Thanks
so much, guys. Um, fun fact, they just
met 10 days ago and they've been just
spamming the hackathons and been winning
quite a lot of them. So, very very
strong team. Um, the next team is Tab
RL. Uh, I think u DT I've met quite a
few times at a number of AIS, right?
This is not your first one. Yeah. Um,
and uh I I think the other interesting
thing about this is the just the
sandboxing that you guys do. that's like
really stands out like um that's what
every single judge that I talked to um
also was commenting on. So uh take it
away.
Hi guys. So I'm Rich. I'm a physicist
and this is my friend Adita and he's an
AI engineer. So we met at the hackathon
and this Saturday and I was very
frustrated about certain things and I
pitched something to him and I was like
we are having this entire automation of
full sex sweet platforms where we have
bold lovable completely doing really
complex backend and front end in the
browser. But we have nothing like that
for robotics. We have nothing like that
to simulate the reality. And so the idea
was born your browser is all you need to
have RL. So we are here to like present
to you what we did on the hackathon.
Next slide please. All right. So we are
using Muja was we using help uh Mujiko
which is a genius platform built by and
acquired by Google deep mind. What it
does it helps you to embed all the
physical attributes in the robots. And
so you can see this like really nifty
really cute uh robots falling under the
gravity. It's basically it just shows
you how these attributes that are only
like present in the physical world are
all embedded in these frames and but the
problem is it's all siloed in Python.
It's extremely fragmented the way this
framework works and it's kind of like
it's only like left up to like robot
robotists to like figure out like how to
like generate like thousand and
thousands of data points and simulations
to invent the future. But we are
changing that. What we're building is
we're building a simulator that allows
you to take a prompt generates different
policies of RL and basically gives this
really really controlled parametrically
and sophisticated simulations. So in a
second we'll switch to All right. So so
here we have we good? Yeah. Sorry about
that. All right. So this is what we
built actually. We built an entire RL
environment that runs in your browser.
In the beginning, we actually built it
in the browser, but then in order to
make it work, the whole idea is
beginners like us can just pick a model
uh in an 3D environment like Richard
just showed you, you can, you know, we
picked a robot dog and we told the dog
like, "Hey, you're a great dog. Show me
how well you can, you know, stick out
your paw. I love you. Like, do you want
a treat?" Right? Uh and the way RL works
is uh the robot throws offs throws off
observations and you need to take those
observations and you need to craft a
custom reward function and usually these
reward functions are only written by
specialists. But what we've done here is
we've used the latest foundation models
to democratize that. So you just put in
your prompt and 03 opus and Gemini all
create three different reward functions
each. And as you can see these are
pretty complicated bits of code. uh you
know they have like all these quarter
neons different rewards for height like
what we ask the robot to do is to sit
and stick its paw out like that's a
pretty complex set of rewards like I I
wouldn't even know where to get started
with the math right but foundation
models they just spit that stuff out and
then once we actually go through and
generate that we actually have these
sandboxes which are kindly hosted by
modal uh where we actually go ahead and
start training all these fine-tuning and
what we end up with is we actually end
up with reinforcement learning and it's
just like magic. So normally you have to
be like a researcher. You have to know
all this stuff but I just typed in a
prompt. Uh my model started training. I
had nine different ones. I'm showing you
one from each provider. I think this is
the one from claude. As you can see I
didn't give it enough steps.
Reinforcement learning takes time. Uh so
it didn't like get the you know start to
converge or whatever but some of the
others ones from Google and OpenAI did.
And yeah long story short um that's
that's our project and uh you know now
you can do it in your browser. We're
really excited to bring this to the
whole world, get everybody start
training the robots on their own
machines. Thanks. Awesome. So overall,
yeah, so closing in, the future is
incredibly bright and if you want to
reach the generalized intelligence in
these machines, we have to optimize for
everything. Thank you guys.
Thank you. Um yeah, that's the I think
the next speaker and I think the last uh
finalist that we have uh I have a
personal relationship with because he
was our first international guest on lat
in space. Um we did it in Singapore I
think. Um and he's been training non
subquadratic non-intention models for a
while. Are you are you plugged in? I am.
Okay. Um and uh he was like I'm just
gonna he was like in the middle of like
some very important meetings but he said
I'm just gonna hack in this hackathon
and uh show you what I can do with my
model. So uh I thought it was like
pretty impressive and uh wanted to uh at
least it was exciting to at least see
him like emerge with something that you
can use today.
Um hopefully this works because he wants
to demo instead of slides.
Okay,
awesome. Take it away.
We can't hear you. Hang on. Your mic is
not on. That's all right. Are you
measuring reliability? Are your agents
following your specification? That's the
question I'm asking. A bit of background
like Sean G is I'm Eugene and firstly
I'm going to say I'm sorry because my
team is working to obsolete all the AI
models you see today. Um this is what we
are working on like you may have seen
some my latest work such as the quirky
72b where we built the world's largest
model without transformer attention. So
this is a 72 billion parameter model
that's a thousandx cheaper inference
cost and performs the same uh based on
the RWKB architecture. We also apply
this technology to accelerate transform
models but that's my background not what
I did in the hackathon to be clear. So
so that's not really that important for
this case. Back to the topic, the boring
topic which is reliability. And this may
sound weird because my hot take is
scaling is dead and we're not going to
solve reliability with scaling cuz to me
right this is a billion dollar money pit
that we are trying to scale and despite
that some of the richest companies on
earth is saying for example the deep
mind founder CEO is saying that it may
take up to 10 year to solve the compound
AI agent error problem. Yan lun say we
need a new AI architecture to solve the
paradigm in AI in robotics and AI. If
you think that they are GPU poor maybe
don't take them seriously. But
furthermore this is also further
reinforced by what we see in production
where 90% of all AI projects fail to to
reach the reach the bar required to for
enterprises. So why does this happen?
Really the problem if you think about it
is reliability because if you think
about it right these AI models are
already capable of orbital physics math.
How many of us can do orbital physics
math from Earth to Mars? You have a one
in 30 chance of you answering correct?
But
who would you use a delivery app that
says it will arrive 45% of the time?
Like think about it like you can do your
order and then maybe he orders 10 pizza
instead of one or the pizza never arrive
and then you're spending spending your
time calling customer support cleaning
up the mess. That is what the best AI
agents right now are doing or even the
best AI model and that's the struggle
that we we are we're having with and
here's what nobody is talking enough
about in my opinion. Most companies
don't need an AI that can do PhD math.
What they really want is an AI that can
do the boring things in life like
booking a flight, sending an email or
processing an invoice without failure
every single time. Scaling is not going
to fix this and in our opinion a new
architecture is needed and that's
something that I can spend an hour
talking but I'll put it aside because
what what we did instead is just to show
it. Most recently our latest action hour
model hit 65% on real eval. This model
will not solve a PhD math equation but
it will do it will do real world web
task such as shopping on Amazon.com dot
dash and etc. And that jump is more than
half compared to clock or gemini which
is at 45%.
So so for those who are asking how it
looks like of course we made an MCP demo
for it.
So that's so if you look at this I'm
just going to run the MCP and pray to
the Wi-Fi gods. So for those who are not
familiar with client, client is awesome
because it can run everything in your
agent uh I mean in your IDE. And I'm
just going to tell it to connect to my
local MCP server which I have already
set it up. And let me double check.
Okay, it's there. Okay.
And then this will this will then do the
task of searching up for a book for AI
engineering on Amazon.com if my API if
my Wi-Fi is working as planned. Okay. So
you see it goes there and it starts to
starts to run it. Um I'm going to say up
front this is not a fast model. It's
going to take five minutes to run. So
I'm going to uh but uh but you can see
like slowly filling up behind the
scenes. So to speed it up I have
prepared a recording in advance uh to to
just show it in simultaneous. Okay. So
you so this is the same thing. You can
see it
going to fast forward a bit. Yeah. So
this is boring. Uh but the point here is
actually about reliability. uh and so so
how do we measure reliability? It's
about running it as many times as you
can. So what I'm going to do
simultaneously
is I'm going to run this on model. So
part of the real eval and shout out to
Dave and and AGI Inc. who who did all of
this is that they provide provide an
endpoint for us to be able to to run it
and against a leaderboard. So, I'm just
going to run it and then it'll just I'm
just launching everything live and it's
going to start filling up this this uh
the scoreboard here. Uh once again, uh
don't have time to run the whole thing.
So, I'm just going to go to the final
result 65%. And to me, this is not
enough. We need to get 99. And that's
what I'm building towards. And to me,
I'm find more frustrating that if
anything, our existing best model can't
even do better than a coin flip. And
that reliability is important because
it's what's going to unlock all of the
your value for all you AI engineers.
This is a billiond dollar market. You
want to make an AI agent that's reliable
in law, accounting, um ordering books.
That's what is going to make you money
and that's what we need. Not a PhD
lawyer. Yeah.
Okay. Uh that's about it. I think I'm
out of time, so I'm just going to jump
straight into Yeah, we have a wait list.
Thank you.
[Applause]
All right, how about we hear it for all
of our hackathon finalists.
Very exciting. So, as mentioned, now all
of you are going to be the judges. So,
um can I get next slide actually?
So you're going to be the judges. So
typically this is done by applause, but
that is so preGBT. So let's go by woos.
So we're going to do a practice round
with all of you in the audience. I want
you to go
one, two, three. Nice. We only have to
do one practice round. Great work. Great
work. Okay, so you ready? I want you to
write down who your top team is. only
want you to woo for that team. I'm going
to get chat GPT advanced voice mode
ready to analyze the results.
Hey chat GPT, I am at the AI engineer
world's fair and we are doing the
judging of the top three hackathon
finalists and now we need your help. We
don't have Wi-Fi. So what we're going to
do is we're going to I don't know why
I'm talking to it like a kid. We're
going to actually do it by applause. So
we have three teams. I'm going to say
team one, team two, team three and each
of them are going to get applause from
the audience. I want you to analyze this
whether actual data measurements that
you have or just perceived and tell us
who the winner is, who number one is,
who number two is, and who number three
is. Are you ready?
Absolutely, I'm ready. Let's do it. Go
ahead and announce each team, and I'll
listen carefully to the applause. [__]
yeah. All right.
Are we ready?
Team one, survival of the future.
[Applause]
Got it. Listening to the applause for
team one.
We just did it.
All right.
Let's move on to team when you're ready.
Awesome. We're ready. We're going
team two tab RL
to team's applause. It's actually woos,
but sure.
I'll listen out for those woos, too.
Whenever you're ready for team two,
team three, featherless action R1.
Wow. Applause for team three.
You failed. I'm sorry. I'm calling
Claude.
No, we have we have human evaluators in
the back who are we knew this was a
gimmick. Yeah, it was a fun gimmick. Uh
but no, thank you for helping us at
least uh give some it gives some sense
of uh you know, sort of audience
participation and uh favorite like it's
meant to be a bit of a people's choice
uh type of thing. So yeah. Yeah. Work.
Okay. Um, okay. So, uh, I So, we're
going to get the results later. I think
Ben, you can talk to them if you if you
need. Um, but we're going to give out
some prizes. Uh, I don't know if the
trace loop team is still around. I
think, uh, near uh I I saw I saw some of
them going out there. Uh, but basically,
we we want to just recognize people
who've been like really, you know,
pulling out their socks for the event.
We got best swag, uh, which is won by
Trace Loop for their keyboard. We got
best dressed uh worn by uh worn by
Madison from B 10. Um I don't know if
any of the B 10 folks here, but um
anyone got the artificially intelligent
uh shirt? Yeah, that that really fun uh
swag. Um and best tweet from Dylan
Patel. Um basically talking about uh a
relationship that was actually started
here um like one year ago, which is
which is pretty sweet. Like that that is
actually heartwarming. We try to get
people hired but we never promise any uh
partners. AI engineer world's fair where
love happens. Yeah, I think that is AI
engineer love fair which uh is a very
high bar. Okay. So then the big
categories that we really wanted to hand
out um obviously uh unfortunately like a
lot of people like leave after your talk
so they can't really uh hand it out but
obviously come come and claim it uh
afterwards if you want. Every track has
best speakers. So um you all voted uh we
actually you know like really care about
giving recognition to the the speakers
who work so hard in their talks and
sharing their experience. Um thank you
to all these tracks. Can I get a round
of applause for MCP David Kramer, Alex
Duffy, Devanchon, Daniel Shaliff,
Harrison Chase, Dylan Patel, Brook
Hopkins, Brian Belelfer, Edamar Freeman,
Dennis Ninkov,
Boris Churnney Lambert, Rafal Vtor,
Daniel uh retita, Renee, John, Sheree,
Nick and Paul. Uh I think the retrieval
one is wrong. Well, retrieval one is
actually W will brick uh who actually
got his prize earlier uh yesterday
earlier as well. Um so those are the
individual track speakers. Um actually
um can I can I get those those uh
picture frames on on there? Um we
actually spent some time um putting
together the uh sort of track speaker
prize. Just one. Thank you. Um and uh
it's like it's like really nice and
printed and we gified everything. So
it's uh so it's kind of cool to see. Um
so yeah, come and get your track speaker
award uh if you uh are still around and
obviously we can send it to you if
you're not. Okay, overall best speaker.
Uh we have a runner up and uh also an
overall uh winner. Um I think uh it's
like relatively uh you know obvious and
and I think like the something that we
wanted to recognize as well for our
keynoters. Um Oh, where is the Oh, okay.
This is not refreshed. Um if if someone
can go back we go back two slides. Yeah,
runner up. Uh, George, are you here from
um um artificial analysis?
Let's hear for the runner up. George,
artificial analysis.
Um, probably they're all in the hallway
track. So, uh, artificial analysis like
worked really really hard in their talk.
They actually like did this whole like
50page report. I was like, George, you
you have 20 minutes. Like, you can't
really can't really do this, but like
they worked super hard on that. And I I
think um it's something that we want to
recognize as well. Um the the winner
though uh it was the by far the
consensus on the people that I talked to
and the committee and all that. Uh the
winner is um you know our third time
keynote speaker. Um he went line dancing
so he's not here today. He's he's not
here to receive the award but I'm
actually going to get Lori. Lori um
you're actually going to receive the
award on behalf of him. Uh it's Simon
Willis everyone.
So
uh no Lori Lori Voss. Lori Voss. We have
two Lori. Sorry, Lori. She's also called
Lori.
Lori, you're you're you're waiting for
the next one. So, um I I don't know you
here. You can you can present the the
best speaker.
Um yes, Simon nominated Lori because
they worked together on Django on where
did you work together? We worked
together at uh Yahoo in 2005. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. So, the Few of the Proud The
Few of the Proud. Yahoo pipes is still a
pipe dream for a lot of people. Uh but
thank you for accepting award on Simon's
behalf. Thank you. Thank you Lori. Um
okay. Um hackathon. Hackathon. You you
have the the second best and it's a
runner up and a best. I don't I was
relying on JGBT. I don't know. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Kind of failed me. Yeah.
Okay. So, do we want to go by
perception? We should we do lose again?
No. No. The audience is thinning. Yes.
They're running They're running
impatient. Uh I think it's probably team
three, right? Okay. Um well, so we have
we have the runner up. Okay. Uh of of of
the hackathon. I I I actually don't know
where to uh price. Yeah, there we go.
Okay. Um so hackathon runner up. I think
uh I think it's like fairly uh pretty
evident I in in my mind. Um it would be
uh the uh the feature
team. So this other Allori uh you can
come up with your team and uh air
come on up. What's what's the team? Come
on up. Yes.
Um
yeah. So you can you can come for rail
this time. Yes, you can come. I'm sorry.
Sorry about that. There you go.
Congrats. Thank you. Thank you. Thank
you. Can I Thank you. Oh, yeah. You
should all you should all definitely
Thank you. Congrats, everyone. Photo
right over here. Thank you.
Thank you. And our website is survival
of the feature.com. Survival of the
feature. Survival of the feature.com.
Please try it. Yeah. Very good. Um and I
think that the winner just decided by uh
votes and uh applause earlier is Eugene
from Featherless. Featherless R1. Here
for Eugene. Where's Eugene?
Uh Eugene gets one of the big ones. Oh
my god, Eugene, you're so excited.
uh fed um yeah federalist has been
grinding away for a long time and uh I
can't believe you did this in a
hackathon uh and u I also like to add
that uh I wasn't alone Michelle
who couldn't be here yeah took part in
the hackathon as well yeah and work on
it with me okay well this is yours thank
you for taking part yeah
stand in the middle Awesome.
Congrats.
That's it. All right, we got to go to
Thanks. All right, now I got to do one
more thing. It's just a quick uh thanks
to everyone who has been part of this.
Obviously to everyone in the audience
here, Microsoft our presenting sponsor,
AWS our diamond innovation partner,
Neoforj Brain Trust who curated our
evals and graph tracks, all of our
platinum sponsors and all of our
sponsors in the expo and beyond. And of
course, Swix, the executive producer and
program curator of this event. It takes
a hell of a lot of work to do that. Leah
McBride, our senior producer, she's been
with us since our very first event in
October of 2023, and she really helps to
make this run. and also our new team
members, Melissa Beily and Scott Dap.
Um, so many others including I want to
give a special shout out to uh Vincent
Wendy who is just all of these
incredible graphics. Everything you see
that was him. Okay, he didn't do the
animation. I'll get to them in a minute,
but he gra he did all that. So,
incredible working with him. VCI events,
this is VCI and they've been running
everything on this floor in Golden Gate
Ballroom level. Uh, Freeman, all the
graphics you see were them. Art and
Display. That beautiful expo in there.
That's like a little Santa's village. I
mean, you feel like you're in a little
mini city there. Incredible. That was
them. Encore helped to run AV up in uh
second floor. Local 16 helps to operate
everything. So, really big thanks to
them. They've all been so incredible.
Motion agency actually did all of the
motion graphics you see here. They're
based in Asia, but they they worked some
of the hours in Pacific for some last
minute stuff. Sunno, I love working with
Sunno. It just can't it doesn't miss
every time. and they produce music just
from text. Uh, the Marriott Marquee,
thank you so much. Max Video Productions
for B-roll. Randall for photography. Uh,
Brad Westfall for and Swix, our web
developer. Come on, how is he actually
doing? And Haley Holmes, our incredible
show caller. Thank you so much. And all
the speakers, of course, they've been so
incredible.
Anyone in a yellow shirt you saw is a
volunteer. They come here just to help
out and be part of the event and the
excitement. So, we thank all them. We
can't run it without you all. So, thank
you so much. And then lastly, I'd like
to welcome on stage the absolutely
hilarious, absolutely wonderful Lori
Voss, our MC. Thank you so much. Can we
give him a big round of applause,
everyone?
I keep telling him this, but his I keep
telling everyone this, but but I keep
telling you this, but your intro was
like his jokes. Did his jokes land or
what? Like, they were actually really
good. They weren't just dad jokes. So, I
really appreciate that and thank you so
much. So, with that, that should do it
for the show. Thank you all for staying.
The last few of you who stayed for this.
Really appreciate it. Thank you so much
for coming out.
[Music]